bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
de ce qui pour certains biologistes et
l'équivalent du big bang pour les
physiciens un court moment de l'histoire
de la terre ou la vie animale s'est mise
à foisonner on appelle ça l'explosion
cambrienne cette période on la connaît
notamment grâce à des faux cils
incroyable découvert au canada et qui
pourrait faire furieusement penser à un
film de science fiction
les fossiles des schistes de burgès
commençons par un petit rappel
chronologique la terre tout comme le
système solaire d'ailleurs s'est formé
il ya environ 4,5 milliards d'années et
étonnamment il semble que la vie soit
apparue assez rapidement puisque les
plus anciennes traces de vie dont on
dispose date d'il ya environ 3,7
milliards d'années c'est à dire
seulement 800 millions d'années après la
formation de la terre
les premières formes de vie étaient des
organismes très simple des
unicellulaires c'est-à-dire constitués
d'une seule cellule comme par exemple
des bactéries plusieurs fois au cours de
l'histoire de la vie sont apparus des
organismes pluricellulaires mais pendant
longtemps ils sont restés assez
rudimentaire sur le plan anatomique au
bout de trois milliards d'années
d'évolution les organismes
pluricellulaires les plus complexes
qu'on pouvait trouver pouvaient être
comparés en gros à des méduses ou à des
éponges ont dit ces organismes qu'ils
ont une symétrie rade hier c'est à dire
qu'ils ont une surface extérieure mais
l'organisation interne reste assez
basique et puis soudainement il ya 542
millions d'années on a vu apparaître
toutes sortes d'animaux très différent
avec une symétrie qu'on appelle
bilatérales ça veut dire qu'ils ont un
devant un derrière un haut et un bas
c'était une grosse révolution anatomique
et surtout une structure interne bien
plus sophistiqué que les précédents
organisme avec des organes un tube
digestif des carapaces un système
nerveux et même des yeux et toute cette
complexité d'organisation est apparue
soudainement enfin soudainement à
l'échelle géologique 1 c'est-à-dire en à
peu près 20 millions d'années
c'est ça qu'on a appelée l'explosion
cambrienne les bestioles typique de
cette époque ce sont les trilobites vous
pouvez en voir un fossile ici on en a
retrouvé des milliers comme ça
d'ailleurs leur apparition soudaine dans
les couches géologiques qui marque le
début de ce qu'on appelle l'ère
cambrienne poser un sacré problème à
darwin
comment expliquer avec la théorie de
l'évolution qu'en si peu de temps temps
de complexité animal soit apparue la
compréhension qu'on a maintenant de
cette période est très liée à un site en
particulier les schistes de burgès il
s'agit d'une carrière qui est située
dans les montagnes rocheuses canadiennes
dans l'état de la colombie-britannique
ce site il avait été découvert au 19e
siècle et on y avait trouvé quelques
fossiles qui ressemblaient à des
crevettes mais enfin sans plus sauf
qu'en 1909 le paléontologue charles
walcott décida d'aller le visiter
pendant ses vacances et il réalisa qu'il
s'agissait en fait d'un site
exceptionnel
déjà parce qu'on trouvait un très grand
nombre de fossiles mais surtout ces
fossiles avaient un niveau 2
ty incroyable et c'était lié au fait
qu'ils avaient conservé la forme des
tissus mous il faut bien voir que ce
genre de situation est extrêmement rare
généralement les animaux sont enfouis
lentement par sédimentation et comme les
tissus mous se dégrade rapidement
les fossiles ne conserve en général que
les images des partis les plus durs des
animaux mais dans le cas de burgès on
pense qu'une coulée de boue ou un
événement violent de ce genre là a
enseveli très rapidement les animaux et
a permis de conserver aussi la forme de
leurs tissus mous walcott a ensuite
consacré les 15 dernières années de sa
vie à fouiller les schistes de burgès et
il en a ramené plus de 65000 fossiles
alors il faut bien voir que quand un
paléontologue ramène des fossiles c'est
pas juste pour les collectionner 1
l'idée c'est de les analyser et de les
classer pour essayer de se faire une
idée d'à quoi ressemblait la faune de
l'époque et comment elles se
positionnent par rapport à celle qu'on
connaît aujourd'hui
à l'époque de walcott ont divisé le
règne animal en sept grands
embranchements les éponges les coraux
les annélides c'est à dire en gros les
verts les arthropodes
les mollusques les échinodermes dans
lesquels on retrouve les étoiles de mer
et les cordes et au sein duquel on
retrouve notamment les vertébrés donc
nous et puis en dessous de
l'embranchement on avait des groupes 1
notamment les arthropodes qui se diviser
en quatre groupes les unira mais les
trilobites les crustacés et les canisses
erat et café walcott avec ses 65 mille
fossiles et bien il les a patiemment
analysé il a essayé de faire des
reconstruction de l'image en trois
dimensions des animaux pour les classer
dans les cases correspondantes
vous vous souvenez par exemple des
fossiles de crevettes il les a appelés
anomalocaris ça veut dire crevettes
anormal et il les a logiquement classé
dans les crustacés les choses auraient
pu en rester là mais cinquante ans plus
tard dans les années 60 et 70 3
paléontologues ont décidé de ré analysé
tous les fossiles trouvés par walcott et
là ils ont eu de sacrées surprises
en analysant les fossiles disponibles et
en essayant de reconstituer de quels
animaux ils provenaient 3 paléontologues
de cambridge
whittington briggs et conway morris se
sont rendus compte qu'il y avait plein
de trucs qui collait pas dans les
classements qu'avait fait walcott et ils
ont fini par comprendre que ce qu'ils
avaient sous les yeux étaient des
animaux complètement différent de ce
qu'on connaissait jusqu'à l'heure des
animaux nouveau pour lesquels les cases
existantes ne convenait pas pour
reclasser les fossiles des schistes de
burgès ils ont dû créer plus d'une
dizaine de nouveaux embranchements alors
qu'il n'avait que 7 à l'époque et une
bonne vingtaine de nouveaux groupes
d'arthropodes alors qu'il n'avait que
quatre et ils se sont rendus compte que
walcott en voulant faire rentrer les
fossiles au chausse pied dans les cases
existantes avec complètement raté le
fait qu'ils avaient sous les yeux
quelque chose de totalement inédit les
fossiles de burgès montre que la faune
qui existait à cette époque non
seulement s'étaient développées
incroyablement rapidement mais en plus
elle était beaucoup plus diversifiée que
ce qu'on s'imaginait avant il ya
vraiment eu une explosion de la vie
animale
à cette époque on va voir ensemble
quelques exemples de ces animaux
fabuleux qu'on pouvait croiser dans les
eaux à cette période
alors à chaque fois on va regarder des
fossiles et on va regarder des
reconstructions en trois dimensions qui
ont été faites à partir de ces fossiles
alors il s'agit évidemment d'une
interprétation un peu artistique mais
rigoureuse
voici par exemple au pam ignace est un
petit animal de 5 à 10 cm qui savaient
nager
il se nourrissait vraisemblablement avec
cette drôle de trompe en forme
d'aspirateurs qui lui permettait
probablement d'attraper sa nourriture
sur sa tête
on peut compter 5 yeux même s'il
s'agissait évidemment d'organes bien
plus rudimentaire que nos yeux actuelle
vous en connaissez beaucoup vous des
animaux qui ressemble à ça la première
fois que les paléontologues ont présenté
en conférence scientifique un dessin
reconstituant cet animal l'audience a
rigolé à les autres exemples à lucie
genia à l'animal qui porte bien son nom
c'est une bestiole qui marchaient au
fond de l'eau et qu'ils avaient des
épines pointu sur une face et des
tentacules sur l'autre pendant longtemps
les spécialistes ont débattu pour savoir
où se trouvait le devant du derrière et
même pour distinguer son os de son bas
on a pensé initialement qu'elle marchait
sur les épines avec les tentacules sur
le dos avant qu'on finisse par se
convaincre du contraire
un des animaux les plus fascinants qu'on
ait retrouvé à burj sc anomalocaris vous
souvenez la crevette anormal et ben
walcott c'était vraiment bien plantés en
fait ces crevettes n'étaient pas des
crevettes mais s'était départi
incomplète d'un animal bien plus grand
qu'on a réussi à reconstituer par la
suite mais seulement dans les années 80
vous voyez ici c'était un monstre des
mers de 60 cm alors ça fait peut-être
pas énorme mais je sais pas si j'aurais
aimé en croisé 1
c'était probablement le plus gros
prédateur de l'époque on pense qu'ils
mangeaient des trilobites
un autre exemple wimax ya un truc
rampant qui avait à la fois des écailles
et des épines et dont on ne sait pas
très bien s'il s'apparente plus au vert
ou aux mollusques aller et pour finir un
animal qui paye pas de mine picard
il ressemble à un espèce de verre aplati
sur les côtés et où alcool qui l'avaient
donc logiquement classé dans les verres
mais non en fait il appartient à
l'embranchement des cordes et vous savez
l'embranchement qui contient les
vertébrés c'est à dire qu'il nous
contient nous aussi alors on n'a
évidemment aucun moyen d'affirmer avec
certitude que pika ya est notre ancêtre
mais il est vraisemblable qu'à l'époque
l'ancêtre de tous les vertébrés actuelle
ressembler à peu près à ça j'espère vous
avoir convaincus qu'à l'époque des
schistes de burgès régnait un incroyable
foisonnement de la vie une fascinante
diversité comme si soudainement la
nature avait décidé d'expérimenter comme
une folle plein de nouveautés vous savez
on parle souvent de l'arbre de la vie
pour exprimer la diversité du vivant et
bien à cette époque la vie animale
n'était pas vraiment un arbre c'était
plutôt une pelouse
c'est à dire que d'état d'anatomie
différentes ont été expérimentées par
l'évolution et il semble que seules
quelques-unes et finalement donné les
animaux qu'on connaît à l'heure actuelle
et tout ça on sait grâce aux incroyables
fossiles des schistes de burgess alors
rassurez-vous depuis on en a trouvé
d'autres un peu partout dans le monde et
notamment au groenland en australie et
en chine
mais qu'est ce qui a pu déclencher cette
incroyable période d'innovation et bien
on le sait pas vraiment une première
hypothèse c'est que l'apparition
d'oxygène dans l'atmosphère et donc dans
l'océan à faciliter le développement de
tout un tas d'animaux de nouveau il faut
bien réaliser calenge il n'y avait pas
d'oxygène sur terre et que c'est la
photosynthèse réalisés par certaines
bactéries qui a permis son accumulation
dans l'atmosphère mais comment le taux
d'oxygène at-il exactement variés à ces
périodes
la question est encore débattues autre
hypothèse une origine génétique il est
possible qu'à cette époque soit apparue
une bonne combinaison de gènes dont les
mutations et permis aux animaux
d'expérimenter assez rapidement tout un
tas de nouvelles formes d'organisation
anatomique dernier groupe d'hypothèses
une perturbation soudaine dans
l'équilibré écologique qui régnait à
l'époque ça peut être une perturbation
externe bien sûr mais aussi un
déséquilibre interne par exemple il est
possible que l'apparition des yeux et
augmenter fortement les capacités de
prédation et donc exercer une pression
de sélection nouvelles sur les animaux
aient mené au
veloppement d'innovation comme la nage
ou bien les carapaces quoi qu'il en soit
à l'heure actuelle on n'a pas
d'explication définitive et l'explosion
cambrienne garde ses mystères
si vous voulez en savoir plus je vous
recommande le livre la vie est belle de
stephen jay gould
j'ai pas mal utilisé pour cette vidéo
alors regardez quand même en tête que le
livre a maintenant une trentaine
d'années et qu'un certain nombre des
choses qu'on y trouve sont à ces remises
en question aujourd'hui notamment la
manière dont on classe les fossiles
aujourd'hui ce fait selon une nouvelle
méthode dont j'ai pas parlé qui
s'appelle la khl a dit stick et qui mêle
à des résultats légèrement différent et
j'en dis un mot dans le billet qui
accompagne cette vidéo un petit mot pour
finir il n'aurait pas été possible de
faire une telle vidéo sans les belles
illustrations qu'il accompagne donc je
voudrais sincèrement remerciés d'un côté
le royal ontario museum
cela fournit un certain nombre de photos
de fossiles et puis c'est très belle
animation 3d des animaux des schistes de
burgès et je voudrais également
remercier nos bougies tamura qui est
illustrateur il va laisser utiliser
certaines de ces images vous pouvez
aller visiter son site et notamment un
grand nombre de ces images sont en
licence creative commons merci à lui
pour cette initiative
merci d'avoir suivi la vidéo si elle
vous a plu n'hésitez pas à liker et à la
partager
vous pouvez bien sûr vous abonner à la
chaîne pour ne rien rater des futurs
vidéo ou bien découvrir les précédentes
vous pouvez retrouver les actualités de
la chaîne sur facebook et sur twitter et
vous pouvez également me souvenir sur
tipi merci à bientôt